In this section of our course, we will get started by learning about the MetaHuman framework
and MetaHuman sample projects.
Let us begin with the question, what is a MetaHuman?
MetaHuman is an Epic Games product that democratizes the creation of engine-ready, high-quality
digital humans.
MetaHuman Creator, released in 2021, is a cloud-based application, allowing users to
create fully rigged, high-fidelity digital characters that can be brought to life in
Unreal Engine easily.
This brings us to the next question, which is, what is the MetaHuman framework?
The MetaHuman framework is the culmination of decades worth of bleeding-edge research
and collaborations with three-lateral and cubic motion, which are part of Epic Games.
MetaHuman, based in Serbia, specializes in creating digital humans using cutting-edge
scan technology and rigging.
Cubic motion, based in the UK, and presently under the three-lateral banner, is focused
on performance-driven, facial animation solutions.
The MetaHuman Creator presets are derived from three-lateral's MetaHuman framework,
using their database from having scanned people's appearances and geometry.
The MetaHuman framework is made up of a variety of collaborating parts, and the assets include
the body and head meshes, skeletons and control rigs, animation blueprints, materials and
animated maps, clothing, grooms, MetaHuman DNA, and rig logic.
A more in-depth look at the assets that make up the MetaHuman framework are covered in
the MetaHuman blueprints and animation course, and the MetaHuman DNA calibration courses.
Now, that's it for this section.
Next, we will take a look at a few MetaHuman sample projects worth exploring.